[موسيقى]
اهلا انا هد بن رضا انا محاميه اماراتيه
هاويه للتصوير بديت في مجال التصوير قبل
سنتين يوم سويت اكونتي على الانستغرام
وكنت اصور خلال رحلاتي يوم اسافر كنت اصور
الطبيعه والاماكن الخلابه
والحين ياسى ان اصور بعرفكم على كيف ان
ممكن تصورون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القمر لازم تختارون مكان مناسب للتصوير
ودام احنا نصور القمر والقمر اضاءه ساطعه
يعني ما شاء الله ان
الطبيعي فيفضل ان يكون
مكان الاضاء ما يكون في لايت بوشن يفضل ان
نعرف مراحل القمر ترى كل ليله القمر يكون
مختلف عن الليله
قبلها تحتاجون تلسكوب للتصوير لو تصورون
بالتلفون لو ما تبون تستعملون
كرات ففي انواع تلسكوب تختلف فيسو خف وثج
لكن حسب انتم شو
[موسيقى]
تفضلون ان لازم تتاكدون انكم مسكرين
الفلاش ان الفلاش يكون اوف عشان القمر
اردي الاضاءه قويه ما شاء اللهبي يعني
بالطبيعه انها دي قويه فما نحتاج اضاءه
زياده يوم تحطون الكاميرا على
عدسه كامرا التلفون على عدسه التلسكوب
ممكن ما تحصلون القمر بسهوله لكن حاولوا
انكم تطلعوه وبعدين ان شاء الله بتحصلون
القمر على شاشه
الايفون لازم تثبتون الفوكس على نقطه
معينه على القمر انا انصح انكم تثبتون على
نقطه غامجه ما يكون ان يعني السطح فاتح ان
يكون الليت وايد قوي تثبتون الفوكس وبعدين
هني تلعبون
[موسيقى]
بالاكسو
ترى كنا نصور في نص البر فتعرفون في
مخلوقات تكون عايشه في البر احنا انا
شخصيا ما كنت اعرف عنها الاستو ان واحنا
ياسين نتصور لازم المكان يكون ما في ليت
يكون ان دارك المكان فانا وانا ياس اصور
كنت ياس اشوف تحت ريدي ان في شي كان يتحرك
فما انتبهت يوم طلع تلفوني اشوف الفلاش
شفت عنكبوت وايد كبير كان جويه من
ريي